a picture is worth a thousand words in
images play an integral part of every
website the HTTP archive has it pegged
at nearly 1.2 megabytes per page which
means images take up 65% of every
website in order to do responsive web
design we need to consider images if the
rest of my page is changing based on
device characteristics wouldn't it make
sense that my images should be changing
too you're absolutely right cam using
the same image but changing the
resolution is probably one of the most
common use cases think providing a
standard image for a laptop but a 2x
image for a high DPI display like a
Chromebook pixel or a retina iMac the
best way to do this is using this source
set attribute on an image tag with
source set the browser will choose which
file it wants and then only download
that one
now that might work for logos and
similar things but what about the case
where I want a different crop of an
image it doesn't make sense to show a
big wide image on a narrow portrait
phone exactly and that's what's called
art direction and where the new picture
element comes in the picture element
uses media queries to select which image
to use but responsive images could be a
course of their own thankfully my good
friend and fellow developer advocate Sam
Dutton has you covered here
hey Sam thanks Pete great stuff when
you're finished with this course if
you'd like to find out more about
responsive images stuff like the picture
element source set come and check out
our course on responsive images thanks
Sam so Pete it seems like we've covered
all the usual elements for responsive
design
what about tables that's a great
question let's take a look cool